actor Billy Porter I did not know who
this was until we did a little check-in
apparently he was on American Horror
Story a couple seasons of American
Horror Story he went on The View and he
sat down with the shrews of the view and
they went off on Ron DeSantis in a
completely insane way enjoy
is this war
trans people
Cabaret and Cabaret people it's a circle
of life yeah you know why are they doing
it for power
yeah everything is about power and you
could always trace it back to the money
you say that all the time yeah you know
it's follow the money follow the power
power at any cost it's very hypocritical
you know the the leading cause of death
in children are guns yes yeah yeah
they're guns yeah I know it's the
morning and I'm not supposed to be
screaming but they're guns yeah
not drag queen no leave us alone
you know and it just it's a distraction
it's a distraction on purpose we don't
know what to pay we don't know what to
pay attention to
all right so I don't know if he
considers himself or herself part of the
lgbtq plus Community or whatever with
the nail polish whatever sort of uh
irrelevant but just to be clear there is
no war on lgbtq people nobody's trying
to arrest them no one's trying to put
them in jail no one is saying that
consenting adults can't live as they
wish really no one in any version of
what happens in this country that is
anything remotely close to mainstream or
has anything to do with the legislative
process in any state no one's coming for
anybody no one's arresting trans people
here in Florida no one's arresting gay
people it's just crazy but there's a war
on trans people that's what he said and
she agreed there's a war on lgbtq does
it what what does I know Q means queer
but what does that mean that just means
you're like you're just like a little
bit like this you'll just kind of sleep
with anyone okay and then uh and then
there's a war on Cabaret
what these people are genuinely insane
The View
years from now they should put the view
in a time capsule and the aliens will
come down one day and they will open it
up and they will watch The View and
they'll be like we better get out of
here
nothing good is happening here
[Music]